[Music]
the satisfying part in repairing
restoring watch is when you're bringing
it back to life
my name is Roland I'm the founder of rgm
watch company and we've been restoring
watches for almost 40 years
we're going to be restoring today a
vintage Rolex military pocket watch from
the World War II era
the first thing that we'll do is we will
visually examine it as one piece all the
parts are original parts on it certain
things will be refinished and improved
other things will be left the way that
they are to preserve the original but
when it comes to the mechanics of the
watch of course that's all vital in the
end we wanted this watch to work very
well but we wanted to look good too
when disassembling the watch generally
the first thing we'll do is remove the
case back and look at the movement the
movement is the mechanism inside the
watch it would almost be like seeing the
engine in a car I can see visually if
you know if there's anything that jumps
out to me that's broken
I'm going to remove the balance bridge
and the balance wheel the balance wheel
is one of the most fragile parts so we
want to get that out off to the side
next we will remove the winding Wheels
at that point we can generally remove
the barrel Bridge which is over top of
the mainspring barrel then we would move
on to removing the train wheel Bridge
then we're kind of getting it down to
where we're going to have wheels by
themselves of course that Escape wheel
will come out
and then we basically have it torn down
to the basic parts
now that we have the watch disassembled
the next step is to start the cleaning
of the parts we have different types of
cleaning baskets and Trays that we can
put those parts in we have little thingy
cylinders that screw together that can
hold tiny Parts the main cleaning basket
itself has trays so that's very useful
in keeping the parts organized and also
preventing them from being lost we'll
generally start in a tank ultrasonic
it's just helping to really
ultrasonically loosen the dirt particles
we will then manually clean Parts also
with pocket watches we often have to
scrape the jewels do a lot of manual
cleaning
a lot of scraping and cleaning pegging
the holes and things like along those
lines
we have a glass jar with a hexane in it
and we use that to clean Parts at the
bench
we just use air to to dry the hexane
which will which will dry quite quickly
and at the very end it will go into a
watch cleaning machine it has a solution
for cleaning but it also has the
physical agitation of the basket turning
back and forth so the combination of all
that will really get the parts very
clean
then they'll be rinsed the same way and
then it goes into a drying sequence
where it's also spinning and that
prevents spotting and things like that
now that we have the preliminary
cleaning done we can get into actually
doing the repair and the the refinishing
of certain parts in repairing this watch
a very crucial area is always the
escapement and the balance hairspring
you know that air that's sort of the uh
the the the hearts of the watch this
particular watch is not running the work
that we're doing is going to rectify
that
here we have the balance wheel being put
on the poison table it will be lightly
touched and and turned so when we find a
heavy spot we will then remove a little
bit of metal this is a very crucial
aspect of getting good timing of the
watch
sometimes especially with older watches
when we get the hairspring it's been
maybe mistreated so we need to try to
get the the coil spacing nice and even
and then we want to make sure the
hairspring is flat over the balance
wheel and not tilted or touching
something
so there's a minute adjustments we have
to do with tweezers to get the
hairspring back into the proper shape
the only part that was replaced in this
watch was the mainspring breath where
the power comes from so we have to take
the main spring and replace it with a
new one so that the watch will have
enough power to run properly so the new
mainspring wound into the mainspring
winder is being pushed from that tool
into the watches mainspring Barrel
and then the barrel Arbor will will go
in the center of that mainspring and
then we have say a lid that will go into
the barrel
some parts it's more Aesthetics
the watch hands were in pretty rough
shape so we made the decision to remove
most of the rust and oxidation that way
we could get them looking much nicer
sometimes depending on the on the watch
the engraving would have paint in it so
we'll redo that we'll clean that really
good and we'll put a black enamel paint
in there
and then let it dry
then we can read the name on it nicely
again the way it originally was
this watch the case was a challenge
someone had tried to remove the bezel in
the back with a knife at some point in
its life and damaged the threads so we
had to carefully rework those threads so
we could screw the back and bezel on the
case obviously had the damage
some people like their case is polished
on Old watches and other people like to
leave them original with that patina on
it we'll make an assessment you know
restoration versus preserving what's
already there
in some situations where it was already
polished or the case is damaged the best
solution may be to polish it
now we're starting the reassembly we're
putting in the Escape wheel fourth wheel
third wheel we're putting in the main
spring Barrel
the center wheel
the bridges that hold them down
we'll then put in the winding Wheels
certain things will be lubricated
there's a number of different types of
lubrication we have to use different
oils and greases
then the balance will be attached to the
bounce bridge and then of course that
will be dropped into the movement also
the satisfying part you know when you've
got things cleaned and and you first put
in that balance and there's first few
ticks and it's running and you're
looking at it you may be the first
person to see this watch running in
maybe a half a century you know that's a
very satisfying moment on the dial side
there are setting parts
we also have the minute wheel and the
hour wheel
from that point then basically it will
then be put back into the case
and then we'll check the how the
finished watch is actually running
this watch certainly is in far better
condition now than it than it was the
day we received it
I think it represents a nice vintage
piece now
it's a pleasing example of this early
Rolex military watch
and it is it's a beautiful it's a
beautiful watch
[Music]
foreign